hello everyone and welcome to the best
game of the penultimate round and most
likely the best game of the tournament
so far
an extremely fighting game that that
took over six hours to finish some uh
six hours and 23 minutes to be exact
uh in again between anishigiri and
alireza firuja so giri is leading the
tournament and he has the y pieces now
against alireza who is trailing by half
a point
uh so without further ado let's check it
out uh hoping this video will not take
as long but it will take quite some time
as there is a lot to cover so let's see
what happened here
we're only gonna discuss the the the
most
important parts so gary with the white
pieces opens with e4 we have
e6 by alireza going for the french
defense and
but he already shown that he is
perfectly capable of playing absolutely
any opening
so d4 we have d5 knight to c3
now uh defending the e4 pawn and knight
to f6
uh we have e5 advancing that pawn so
going for the stein it's variation
knight to d7 and now f4 strengthening
that pawn in the center as black will
most likely challenge the d4 pawn by
advancing c5
this is what alireza goes for c5 we have
knight to f3
knight to c6 and now bishop to e3 adding
more
at the defense that e3 pawn and now a6
we have a3 so this is all very standard
stuff has been played before we have
captures on d4
knight captures and now bishop the c5
getting
this bishop into the attack queen to d2
uh and now black castles and here gary
goes for queen to e2 he also prepares
the castle
we have queen to c7 by alireza and now
uh there are some games where rook to d1
was played also bishop to g4 is a known
move
uh but here geary castles and it is as
of move 12 that we have a completely new
game
so let's see uh how alireza continues he
plays b6 he wants to think out of his
light square bishop
to get a hold of this long diagonal and
of course connect rooks and bring them
into the game
and here already something very
interesting happened well i thought it
was interesting
geary first captured on c6 all it is
recaptured and then
uh giri went into a deep think of some
10 minutes
it's not a very deep thing but you know
for for such a decision
it is quite a lot so i always find it
amazing that first he captures the
knight and only then he starts thinking
for like 10 plus minutes
uh because he knows the knight must be
captured but he only then
uh wants to you know work everything out
but okay that's how
that's how you know chess is played at
the absolute top level and here
b4 uh challenging this bishop here and
the problem is if you go back for
example bishop to e7 bishop to d4
and there really isn't a good way for
black to ever activate
any of his pieces and white will just
have a very natural development bringing
both rooks into the game
while black will be stuck with with
absolutely no plan whatsoever
so instead after b4 uh alireza goes for
bishop captures on e3
queen captures and now bishop to b7
we have bishop to d3 and now comes
already a very very exciting move uh and
that is
d4 attacking the queen and threatening
checkmate
uh but no this does not end the game uh
it'd be funny if it did but the queen of
course will defend against checkmate so
here
you have two options you have queen e4
or you have queen h3
queen h3 is very very very tricky
because here black would capture the
white knight
on c3 is still under attack captures
captures and now after the bishop is
captured you will then capture on c3
and we get this end game bishop against
knight with both players having two
rooks um
very interesting but nothing uh to hope
for pretty much for
for the white pieces so gary instead
goes for the a bit more ambitious
queen to e4 and now it's not black who's
threatening checkplate but
rather white who's threatening checkmate
so let's see what happens here
queen captures an e4 and now knight
captures an e4 if
giri just trades everything off for
example captures captures
then it's uh pretty much an instant draw
and gary still likes his chance he has
the white pieces and if he gets a win in
this game
uh then of course this goes a long way
he will be
a i had a full point ahead of everyone
and uh uh for the final round that
that's excellent
chances for actually winning the
tournament so here we have
knight captures on e4 now saying okay if
you want to trade i will be the side
that has the bishop
uh and now bishop to d5 by alireza here
he might have some plans playing b5
maybe bishop to c4 maybe try to get his
pawn to c4
if possible and gary goes knight to g5
if gary wants he can just trade
everything off with c3 for example d
captures knight captures
attacks the bishop and after bishop to
b7 rook 8 to c1 and he now
grabs hold of the of the open c file
after b5 and g3
black will play rook after d bring this
rook to c8 and it would be
again a pretty pretty equal-ish position
so okay after bishop to d5
with knight to g5 by geary instead now
going after this
h7 pawn and alireza needs to figure out
how to go about this and he decides
to defend with the g6 another
interesting idea is f6 trying to get
white to capture on h7 to try and trap
the knight
but after for example captures and
captures white will go back with knight
to f3
if you capture this then just rook f7
and the knight does not have an escape
square black will gladly of course give
up the rook for for knight and bishop
so instead of that we have g6 now simply
not allowing the capture
and now gary just goes back knight to f3
and alireza says
all right now the pawn structure has
changed a little bit it's a very close
position
and my knight could even be a little bit
better than your bishop and he goes for
bishop captures on f3
rook captures and b5 but it's still it's
still not very easy these pawns are
stuck on light squares giri has a light
square bishop uh
could be could be very interesting so
bishop to e4
now going after that b7 square but it
comes with an attack on the rook and
here we have
rook 8 to d8 uh
just getting the rook behind this pawn
here because some someone also needs to
be defending this pawn
so rook to d3 and now comes knight to b6
and
this is a brilliant move by alireza
because you know that gear is going for
not
that but he's going for brook to b7 and
like we said these spawns are on light
squares
so this is where the fun starts for real
uh bishop to b7 was played going after
the pawn here
and it's a very dangerous position for
black so feel free to pause the video
and try to find the absolute best way to
continue this for alireza
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh congratulations to everyone who
found it as you are
a true master of the end game and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it's
night the a4 and this is just uh amazing
stuff
uh if you're interested about a
situation on the clock it's 22 minutes
geary and alireza
uh still has 25 minutes and it's only
moved 25
so 15 more moves until players reach
time control
so uh bishop captures an a6 it's it only
makes sense and now
knight to c3 and now the idea is knight
to e to check and pick off the f4 pawn
but the problem is
you don't have the option of actually
defending the pawn because if you
kind of play king to f2 or something
like that take away the e2 square from
the knight
then rook the d7 and now the bishop does
not have an escape square rook to a7 is
coming and that bishop is gone
you would have to play something like a4
to save your bishop but after b
captures on a4 black is now very very
happy with his
with his very own past a pawn so instead
after knight to c3
bishop immediately goes back to b7 and
geary sees that he needs to allow this
knight to e2 check
and alireza goes for it 92 check king f2
knight captures an f4
attacks the rook we have rook to d2 and
now again
what do you play here uh well it's it's
an end game the time is
ticking the clock is ticking and uh you
have to play something here a move like
f6
goes a long way definitely for example
captures captures and then
uh the the white king isn't in a really
great
position here these two squares taken by
the knight and by the pawn so
white would have to go back and black
kind of uh
wins more space e5 is coming and you
know it it is just all good but here
alireza again
played the d3 and this is just crazy
stuff so let's see
let's see what what he had in mind here
uh the point is if king to e3
then it's going to be very dangerous
because for example if d
captures on c2 now you for example trade
captures captures this is not force this
is
just something that exists in the
position just to show you how dangerous
it is
uh andy if you grab the knight rook d1
just wins for alireza
as you you either trade and allow white
to bring a queen into the game or you
have to play something like this
but it's not it's not much better
characters and then bishop captures but
black will of course win the same game
easily
so that's one of the things that was in
the position another thing is after d3
you could go for this very amazing c4
but seeing c4
is much easier said than done point is
after b
captures on c4 it looks crazy giving
black to
uh connected past pawns uh but what you
want to play is
rook to c1 you stop those pawns and now
you enjoy your own past a
and b pawn and if rook to b8 you play
rook
captures on c4 that's the idea the
knight here is undefended and after
captures captures
white just has an amazing endgame most
likely a winning one
so this was in the position after this
uh d3 move
uh but giri played not c4 he rather
played c3
uh just to to prevent this this idea but
now alireza
does does get a movie and he plays
knight to e2
and again a very very tricky idea what
do you do here
uh you have to play something and that
that knight is a beautiful piece so what
do you do here
here uh we have kink the e3 but there
were
some other options for example a4 is an
idea and that for b captures on a4
you might be able to go rook to a3 uh
but still it's a very very
very tricky stuff for example rule b8
goes after the bishop the bishop to c6
now
if rook beat the c8 then b5 white starts
advancing his past pawn so
a lot of ideas that involve pushing a4
and c4 are in the position but
giri decides to to play it safe he's
leading the tournament
and any pawn push that you know isn't uh
winning might be losing so here king to
e3 by giri
and now comes knight captures on c3 we
have rook captures on d3
and now rook captures on d3
and here all it is uh got a bit careless
for example uh
rook the b8 might be a little bit better
going after the bishop bishop c6 now
knight a4
and uh he holds a very very uh
the position very nicely however after
rook captures on d3
all it is a captured with check we have
king captures and the knight the a4 but
now
uh believe it or not this is uh winning
for geary by
force uh giro goes rook to c1 and
what do you do here we have rook to d8
check and now
king to e2 king the c2 is winning
but it would be it's easier if
if we just continue the game and then
you will understand why king the c2 is
winning right away
uh because we're gonna reach that exact
same position in a few moves so king the
e2 was played
we have king to g7 by alireza and now
bishop the c6 going after this b5 pawn
and now rook the b8 defending uh so
uh just uh just defending the pawn and
both of them are extremely low on time
and
they still have four more moves to make
before they reach time control
and here we have rook to c2 rook to c2
is uh
a very sneaky idea by giri that kind of
uh gets us to the position that we
already could have gotten but
it doesn't matter because here you could
go king to d2 without
this advancement of the pawn for example
if rook to b6 you're gonna go bishop to
f3
and now you'll see why this is so sneaky
if rook b8 black just claims white
doesn't have a winning plan here
rook the c7 rook to b6 again black
claims you have nothing
king to c2 rook to b8 and now bishop to
c6
attacking this pawn here so black must
remain on the b file
rook to b6 and now bishop will go to e8
and we have this
very very uh winning position for white
so
this this is also possible in the
position however after rook to b8
rook to c2 like i said both very low on
time and gary has a very clear plan
he now wants to sneak the king behind
this rook
go over to b3 with the king pick up the
spawn
rook captures and then eliminate the
knight with the king
and enjoy the two connected past pawns
on the queen side so this is his plan
and alireza goes king to f8 everyone
thought aliereza was going to play g5
with the idea of bringing the king into
the game very early on and creating some
of the past pawns of his own
but he went king to f8 instead so he
still waits with this idea we have king
to d2
king to e7 we have king to c1 giri
continues with
this uh uh
advancing the of the king to the queen
side and
only now alireza plays f6 which is a
little bit weird as he could have played
that
uh you know three moves ago uh but the
thing is
uh both of them are now uh below one
minute and still with two moves to make
with e captures on f6
king captures on f6 and king to b1 gary
going for that b3 square with the king
and now comes king to e5 and now with
king b5 king b1 and king to e5 both
players reach time control and now they
can relax a little bit
uh but giri knows his plan he doesn't
need to relax king the a2
king to d4 by alireza and now king to b3
and now
uh giri is ready to pick up the b5 pawn
rook captures and king captures on a4
uh and now uh interestingly for example
if e5 it does seem like black is very
fast in pushing
of that past pawn but just a rook to
rook to d2 with check and if king e3
then you get a rook to d5
if e4 then rook e5 and you are losing
that past pawn
so it's not as fast as it seems so after
king to d3
after king b3 we have king to d3 now not
allowing
the rook to defend through the second
rank
and now comes rook to f2 and here
uh is where things got really tricky
because if
you go for bishop captures on b5 now
rook captures and king captures it's
still perfectly possible to play this
but uh you you had to calculate a lot of
stuff the problem is
uh if the rooks get traded off for
example king captures
king captures here then of course the
position is completely winning
and it's not a problem we're just going
to show very quickly for example if e5
first king c4 force the black king to
move closer to the pawn king d2 and now
you push the b
pawn and now we're going to get e4 b6
we're going to get
e3 b7 e2 white will queen on the b
file black will queen on the e file and
now queen to b for check
trades the queen and then pushes the a
pawn to victory so this is the plan
problem is after king captures an a4 you
don't have to trade the rooks you can
just play rook to b8
and then the game continues and well it
requires uh
much more to calculate this you're still
only up upon so
uh giri decides against this so after
this king to d3
gary says okay first i'm just going to
move my rook and then i'm going to play
this so
pretty much the same stuff we just don't
trade
this way and it you know perfectly fine
for me however
here e5 is coming and now comes rook to
f7 by giri
again if you if after this e5 move you
go bishop captures on b5 right away
then the problem is after rook captures
king captures this pawn
is already very very close and the rook
on f2 will just
give an additional tempo to black to
push the pawn rook to b8 e4 is coming uh
sorry b5 e4 and so on black will be
black will be sufficiently fast not to
lose this game
so gary goes back rook to f7 and now he
says okay
i still have all the tension i had on
the queen side and i might even start
picking off this kingside pawns
so here alireza goes knight to b6 and
this is a very important move
uh as there was a lot to consider if you
rush in with e4 there are various ways
for gary to defend the rook to d7 check
king e2 you're going to go rook to e7
attack the pawn and after the pawn is
pushed to the dark square
rook to e5 now and now what do you play
here if knight to b6 you're gonna
capture on b5 with check
king to d2 and you are never crossing
that e2 square
as white has all the defense in the
world and will now just start pushing
his past pawns
so instead alireza finds a knight to b6
and now
finally we have bishop captures on b5
with check
king to d4 and now a4 gary now starts
pushing his pawns
and now comes knight to d5 and here
what you definitely should go for is
rook to d7 but rook to d7 again not
an easy decision to make because if rook
the d7 it seems like you don't have any
moves for example
rook to b6 prevents bishop to c6
so you don't lose any any material the
knight here in particular and now it
seems like you don't have a move you
cannot move the bishop because rook
captures with
check and what can you play you cannot
push the pawn because the bishop falls
it seems like white has no moves problem
is
white is still winning after king to a3
you just uh don't allow this to come
with
check and then after e4 you just play
bishop to e2 and now of course there's
no point in capturing this because
captures with check eliminate you
eliminate the rook and then you just
continue pushing your pawn
so this was the way to victory but
gearing decides against that he plays
rook captures on h7 and now
uh of course the position is still very
much winning for white
but uh it gives a new lease on life so
here alireza starts pushing the past
pawn
and now rook the f7 by giri uh
you could also go for something like
rook to h6 but most definitely not
rook to h4 because then g5 is very very
annoying you don't really have a good
square for your rook
and uh well it's just going to be uh
it's just going to be weird playing this
so after e4 we have rooked the f7 by
giri and now e3 continuing to push that
pass pawn
rook to f1 by giri and now knight the c3
so what do you play here we have rook to
f4 with check
king to e5 and now comes rook to f3
threatening to pick up this pawn
and now the idea is if alireza defends
it again then giri had in mind
uh rook captures an e3 this beautiful uh
temporary uh
not temporary but uh an exchange
sacrifice
king captures king captures knight and
now of course this will be completely
winning for white
because uh there's nothing to do here if
you go after the pawns bishop c6 defends
and now the past pawns are just gonna
win the game on the spot
so after rook to f3 we have knight
captures on b5 by alireza
going after this rook end game rook
captures an e3 with
check we have kinked at d4 and now
rook to g3 so attacking the g6 pawn
but now knights the d6 by alireza uh we
rook the g6 and now comes knight to e4
so
giri parted with his rook but he does
have a four pass
he parted with the knight but he does
have four pass pawns and this is of
course uh
completely winning for white with
perfect play uh if i might add
and the situation on the clock is uh uh
we're currently at mu 54
21 minutes uh for giri and 12 minutes
for ferugia so
let's see what happens here gear starts
pushing we have a5
and now king to d5 uh we have a6 by giri
and now knight the c5 with check and
this is an amazing move by ferruja
uh it seems like it's going after the
queen side pawns but actually knights
the c5 check
is directed at going after the king side
pawn so knight c5
check king a3 and now knight to d3
with a double attack on this pawn here
but now giri advances
a7 uh we have rook to a8 and now rook to
g7 defending
and now king to c6 by firuja uh we have
h for baigiri now starting to push the
other side of the past pawns
and now comes uh knight to f4 and this
knight the f4
is an amazing move uh because again it
puts white
at an incredibly difficult position
where only one move
actually wins the game for giri uh so
feel free to pause the video
for the last time and find the winning
idea for gary while i give you a couple
of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations as this is uh once
you see it of course you
immediately believe it but uh you know
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show
it's kinked a4 king to a4 with the
amazing idea of
guarding the b5 square and now the
problem is after knight to e6 attacking
the rook
you first play b5 check king to b6 and
now
you pin the knight at rook to g6 you
give up the a7 pawn with
check king captures king to b4 and now
rook to e7 defends the knight but now
h5 and now the game the game continues
but white will have
a winning position for example if king
c7 on pins
the king h6 is coming if king to d6
then comes b6 and it's just going to be
a winning position for white
however after this knight to f4 move and
i also want to mention instead of
knights to f4
you could also go for king to b6 i
forgot to mention just going after the
a7 pawn
but this is not enough you just push the
h5 pawn if captures with check
white will happily trade captures
captures and push h6
and it seems like you are in time to
stop the pawns but not really h7 you're
gonna go knight f7
now g4 and after king to b7 uh you're
gonna go
g5 of course the knight cannot uh
capture the pawn because of queening
so knight's the h8 but now the knight
cannot go anywhere you're just gonna
bring the king over there
uh win the knight and that's it because
the black king cannot keep an eye on
this pawn
and also on the king's side so just
wanted to mention that as well
but okay after knight to f4 we set king
to a for the only winning move but geary
played the g4
and now alireza needs to find a
brilliant
brilliant
defensive maneuver knight e6 attacks the
rook
uh we have rook to f7 and now
knight to c7 so he blocks the rook's
defense of the a7 pawn
and now the rook can capture the a7
point without actually being traded off
so g5 gear starts pushing the pawns on
the king side
rook captures with check king to b2 and
now comes rook to a8 you could also go
rook a4 king b3 and then rook back to
it but alireza says there is no point in
doing this but still
there are two connected pass pawns on
the king side so let's see if alireza
can stop them we have
g6 and now knight to e6
we have h5 and now comes rook to h8 and
now you see
it's very very hard to push those pawns
this pawn is under attack so of course
giri blocks it rook to h7 but now rook
the g8
and it was in this position on move 67
that uh giri and ferruja agreed to a
draw as
there is no more way for white to make
progress here uh whatever you do here
you can't really move any of the pawns
if you push the h pawn then this pawn
falls
uh you cannot push this pawn because
it's defended
twice and whatever you do let's say you
play king to c3 or b3 doesn't really
matter king c3
uh you're gonna get knight to f4 and now
there's a very simple idea of how to
draw this if g7 you can just pick up the
h5 pawn
real captures rook captures and this is
a well-known uh
draw drawn position uh where white will
not have
any means of making progress here uh so
yeah
really really amazing stuff uh and this
game was
a real roller coaster um alireza really
played
played actively with the black pieces he
he achieved pretty much everything he
took away all of white's advantage right
from the opening and
he he really tried to to keep uh
everything
on the table he tried to go for a win
this game even if it's against the
tournament leader with the black pieces
uh but gary he had so many so many
uh moments in the game where he could
have won but i think the problem is that
this is
geary never won the tata steel
tournament and this is his first
uh good chance of no he he had other
good chances
uh but um he once uh got shared first
with magnus and then he lost the magnus
which means he didn't win the event
but here he i i think he was just
afraid of not of playing like the
winning move and then losing the game so
that i think that was the problem here
you were thinking about winning the
tournament and then maybe you
you failed to win the game but you can
see how resilient alireza was here
when when it was uh time to play the
engine move he found the engine
when it was time to play us well a weird
complicated move he he played that
and in the end it worked out he got a
draw with the black pieces
after a gruesome six and a half hours of
play and
let's just check it out these are the
standings after uh penultimate round and
we are going into the final round with
this and these are the correct standings
uh
if i might add so giri still leading the
tournament with aidan
with eight out of twelve then with seven
and a half out of twelve we have three
people jordan van forest alireza
ferrugia
and fabiano corona all three of them
with chances of
winning the tournament then andre
sipenko
with seven out of 12 magnus carlsen with
six and a half out of 12
with six uh pentala harry krishnan and
niels grandelius with five and a half
aryan tari with five young shisht of
duda and maxine vashilagrav
uh david anton giharo with four and half
out of twelve and radoslav
check with uh sorry also with four and a
half out of 12 and alexander donchenko
with three and a half out of 12.
so really really exciting stuff and for
those of you who are interested
uh for the uh for the first place i'm
just gonna mention tomorrow's pairings
uh so you guys know what's happening
here uh let me just
check real quick so in the final round
uh
firuja will be facing uh radoslav and
interestingly uh the magnus carlsen is
facing maxine vashir lagrave but that
game will have no effect
whatsoever understandings of who
actually wins the tournament so
really really weird stuff anish giri
will be uh
facing david antonihara with the black
pieces
and van forest who also has a great
chance of winning will be facing niels
grandelus
so oh it all depends on what what
happens tomorrow
uh and it's going to be it's going to be
a pretty pretty wilder day
so yeah that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it really a tough break for giri
because he's gonna have to play in the
final round
maybe thinking oh i really messed up
yesterday whereas alireza will you know
uh feel like he he conquered the world
after getting a draw
from the sand game uh but yeah it's
gonna be really awesome
so yeah uh that's the game hope you guys
enjoyed it uh
like i said it it didn't take six and a
half hours uh
like like it did in the real world uh i
would like to thank anil kulkarni uh
john nicely thomas gallagher
uh robert stenberg and
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the tata
steel of the final round checking up on
your wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so thank you all i will see you
soon and
have an excellent rest of your day